welcome back to mlst folks I've had the
great honor and privilege of being
invited to the creative machine event at
Oxford it's organized by Professor
Frederick lamari and many academics have
been invited to present on artificial
intelligence and creativity and art in
particular now I've done a whole bunch
of interviews this afternoon and I'll be
publishing them over the coming days but
um yeah I'm just really really
appreciate this opportunity and I've had
a lot of fun so yeah cheers a combined
speech synthesis and speech recognition
with a chat dot but I called it myself
and train on the dialogue of 100
000 films
wow it was such a big number at the time
it was like several gigabytes of data it
was enough to cover for a diverse
comedic situations and I quoted Alex an
acronym for artificial language
experiment the audience would give
suggestions and I had to adapt and to
improvise in response to whatever Alex
would respond and I was trying to work
with a robot getting to tell interesting
and committing stories and of course it
was a hilariously impossible task okay
Fabs so
um
piota it's amazing to meet you very nice
to meet you
um I actually want to give you a demon
demonstration of X-ray glass
which is a super cool application that
we've designed originally to help deaf
people and then to help people translate
and then to do large language models so
he's gone the uh okay we've gone around
the houses
so
nebula is the application that comes
with these glasses so you go into XR
space okay and then
you go into our app
which is x-ray glass
so you have to connect it to have it
connect it to a phone
without using it the newer glasses have
a computer built in okay so all of the
old school glasses like this they're
basically a glorified accelerometer and
display okay and the new ones are
amazing they've even got cameras on as
well okay so go to XR subtitles yeah and
I guess camera was a big thing that uh
didn't help the popularization of a tool
no whereas what you really want is the
screen
okay
now we support loads of different
transcription engines this is using the
Microsoft Azure one which is actually
one of the best ones and one of the
cheapest ones and what you should see is
that it just doesn't make any mistakes I
can just keep talking as quickly as I
want I'm talking very very quickly it
doesn't make any mistakes at all sure
you're a native English speaker
uh I am not
so I'm going to speak like I normally
speak
and uh yeah already naughty speak
naughty speak already got it
um yeah so
hey well Welcome to our improv comedy
show tonight
um we have a fantastic cast there is
Sarah and there is Boyd and there is
pioter
translated as Peter oh my God
okay but here I'm I'm making comments
about the specific condition I shouldn't
because you can plug pretty much
everything
to it but uh so what I like oh that's
interesting it actually latches to the
the position and so and you can pin it
as well Aha and so it follows me so
that's why so if I move my head it
follows slowly yes this is cool
isn't that insane yes so what's the API
that's the only question that counts the
API as in which transcription engine do
we use uh
I want to send text to it oh oh well we
haven't made one yet but we're going to
okay yeah so we already have an API but
we don't expose it yes and um what we're
actually going to do with the API is
have a websocket interface with a stream
of not only transcriptions but also AI
um entities okay so you can build these
prefab templates for chat GPT yes and
there are two types of templates there
are streaming templates and there are
interactive templates okay so the
streaming template is I've got a deaf
accent and I want to correct the
transcription yes or another one might
be an interactive template which is I'd
press the highlight button so this is a
highlight and there might be an event
there might be a person reference you
see anything you can come up with you
just write a template okay you plug it
in and then you can subscribe to the
stream of metadata so it goes through a
template so it means that if I want to
get instructions like and scene get off
stage now
I can have a template yes anything
fantastic yes
um it's actually really interesting
we've had so much interest from theaters
yes yeah
um but you're coming at it from the
different sites so normally it's helping
people
um
kind of understand what's going on
better so sometimes there's
non-linguistic information so we could
use computer vision sometimes it's just
basic transcription yes sometimes it's
synchronizing with a script so there's
some fluid elements and there's some
scripted elements yes and being able to
kind of like have a mixture of the two
with some event synchronization yes
okay because
um you're only sending text strings
at the moment at the moment okay but
that's already a lot I mean a special
theater that's what you all work with
well it's surprising actually from the
linguistic domain how much
kind of quite subjective and extra
linguistic information you can infer
that's another discussion that we can
have but going multimodal is really
interesting because we can robustify the
speaker diarization we know who's
talking we can do event you know and
visual action detection so we can
synchronize or detect certain things
it's also about awareness of the
environment that you're in you know the
doorbell rings or this has happened yeah
and you've got these Google Maps layers
on your visual field yes
if you were on our team what would you
build next on that software
um
well
just very quick question like sending
any kind of text
um so not even going for a template
interface uh you prefer to keep
um
an API that works with um templates
rather than working with just
pure streaming of text
well we are schematizing it so that the
prefab templates they have a structured
Json output and that's the way that we
link it into our application okay so the
default is the application sees
everything as an utterance string okay
but if it has a schema then we will
parse it in the in the application and
we'll do some specific I see yeah I mean
a good example is summaries so we have
streaming summaries it's very similar to
how the summaries Works in Discord and
so when it sees a summary entity it
knows that it'll render it at the top
and when you're kind of like scrolling
through the conversation it will show
the summary that was nearest to that
time point
okay I see so first thing to add
um maybe start well moving into images
you can start with icons
and display that is on different sides
so right now the text into the middle uh
I imagine that there is something about
the visual field that is limited but
already having something about
uh placing characters on One aligning on
one side or the other side two people
talking like I'm talking to two people
and the Ally is left aligned left and
right aligned yes depending on who is
talking yes yes uh or just having arrows
for directions
and you know because at the moment it's
so basic so we're not even using the AR
that much so we're just kind of
rendering the captions onto a plane and
imagine when because that's only three
dot so the newer ones are sixth off and
they actually have spatial awareness of
the room around you and you can detect
where the people are you're talking to
and then you can draw the captions over
their heads and just think about other
types of spatial awareness as well so
it's not just people it's objects in
your environment
the cool thing you don't need any eye
tracking because the glasses are fixed
yes so
um
it essentially detects where you're
looking at based on
the head position yes your head pose
and it's still doing well it's following
yeah it is following me yeah well I mean
this is easy accelerometer
um
what do you think it's fantastic it's
really fantastic yeah oh and uh
you don't do you I mean you do need a
gyroscope
do you
um I don't need a job because you're
always project in the front yes that's
right there's just an accelerometer in
there yeah no gyro
yeah I love it I absolutely love it
isn't it a cool piece of tech because
those glasses it's basically just an
HDMI interface and an accelerometer and
some speakers and mics
um do you know what they we were using
the mic from the phone and that's
because the mics built in there have
beam forming and it's because they're
designed for voice commands so they're
really good at picking you up yes but
they don't if you're over there they
don't pick you up yes which is why we're
using the the mic in the phone but of
course we support bluetooth mics
Bluetooth oh my God you know you don't
bring Bluetooth on the stage
oh it's absolutely disconnected but uh
the idea of microphones it was my uh
yeah it was microphones are folded in
the pocket then it becomes basically
everyone everyone has a microphone
everyone has a screen yes you can get
instructions and it's uh
yeah I know it becomes beautiful but I
don't want to run out of time so let me
let me just introduce you a little bit I
think you can just talk about some of
the cool stuff so um I filmed your
amazing talk earlier and we'll show that
of course in in the in the the
presentation but you um well you're a
staff research scientist at deepmind yes
and I'm going to skip the bio a little
bit just to save time because we can add
that on afterwards but the really cool
thing is you co-founded human machine
and improbotics yes two artificial
intelligence improvised theater
companies and you're exploring AI art
generation at deepmind specifically
generative Visual grammars and collages
and as a theater maker and researcher in
AI you believe in an interdisciplinary
approach to Arts and Sciences and your
vision is to explore new forms of human
theater through the help of state of the
art research in artificial intelligence
and Robotics and to highlight what is
uniquely human Guided by artistic
collaboration now the thing that
fascinated me is that you said you see
the skill of theatrical improvise as one
of the highest forms of human
intelligence and by confronting humans
to the incongruity of machines on the
stage we can create new opportunities
for absurdist comedy cross-cultural
connection and interactive storytelling
absolutely fascinating I mean could you
explain what you meant by this
improvisation as being the highest form
of intelligence yes of course I am
biased because I improvise
um that there is something when you go
and watch someone improvise either doing
jazz or any kind of music improvisation
or
theater compromisation
where you laugh at the person's
intelligence you laugh with their
intelligence because you realize that
they are they are actively listening to
what happens around themselves
um
and they adapt constantly
so if intelligence and there are so many
possible definitions of intelligence but
if intelligence was defined as problem
solving under any circumstance and
adaptation improvisation would be it
yes and this is very related to the
concept of surprise and information
Theory
um because in a way language models have
told us or taught us that there's not
much novelty in the world in discourse
in thinking that's the reason why it's
such a truncated model of computation
works so well colloquially but I've
always had the impression that comedians
as well
there's something about performance
which is always playing with surprise
right it's and it's it's also the
complexity the Nuance in every situation
yes yes
um what performers do is a mixture of
mental training that allows them to
receive new bits information and not get
destabilized
yes and so not get into the head
not lose the contact with the audience
and effectively
like a musician that is able to play the
um
uh didgeridoo why breathing they
maintain that connect that flow that
connection with the audience while they
are finding the next thing to do the
next thing to say
when you say flow let's explore that a
little bit because you're talking about
some kind of deep ontological relation
with the audience some shared experience
and it's it's a one-to-many right is
there some kind of aggregation function
over the experience of everyone in the
room
yeah that's true so you tend to pick up
a few people uh with whom you think you
have a good relationship in the audience
and maybe ignore other ones yes uh so
there is already a selection process
happening here yes
um
and um
so essentially it's about Distributing
attention I guess over uh individual
members of the audience of the time yes
but what is that thing you know when you
go to a music concert you go to the
theater and there's this visceral
shared experience
you know I joked about it I guess the
other week you know you you send a video
to your friend on WhatsApp they don't
get it
what what is it
um a form of communication I think uh I
so I would like to add a disclaimer I'm
I'm kind of riffing a little bit on this
as someone who is effectively
essentially a computer scientist who
loves theater and improv and who
discovered those things
but my feeling is
um that there is something unique about
a shared experience that everyone ex has
simultaneously uh knowing that everyone
receives in a slightly different way yes
because they mix their perception with
their own culture and
their own state of mind
um and um
well I guess it's quite
um
beautiful in this collective experience
is the individual freedom of every
member of the audience in receiving
that information and interpreting it in
their own way
yes and this is the the beauty of art so
there's the Aesthetics there's the
intention there's what you're
experiencing and then there's a spectrum
isn't there on the one side is the
subjectivity it's the infinite
Divergence of experiences based on all
the things that they've done yes and on
the other side there's quite an
objective ontology which is you've kind
of a bit like the bias variance
trade-off you've created biases to kind
of like create a cone of possible
subjective experiences yes and so some
some of it is controllable and some of
it diverges and like where where is is
that Spectrum just
do we understand anything about it I
don't know gosh you know so much more
about this under me
um I feel like a throat
um so
what is
yeah so so you said that there is
um a whole multiplicity of subjective
experiences
yes and at the same time
we are
you're parents think the same thing
well we we always feel we're
experiencing the same thing I think
that's an illusion but I I think there's
a component of shared experience like
objectively and then there's let's say
20 percent
and then 70 is huge Divergence but you
know we have this weird psychological
thing that we have different subjective
understandings of the same thing so you
might have a different understanding of
what that light is but we still just use
the word light and it's appointed to the
same thing but we understand it
differently
yeah so I think the um
being very personal here I am
just because I grew up in different
places and I've been living in different
countries yes I end up experiencing
um pop culture as maybe slightly
differently from uh from a person has
been always living in a in a given place
um and I don't and I missed some
references
uh and I may be picking up on other
then
the um
okay could I touch on that is Art about
it's not like it's about communication
per se it's not like you're delivering a
packet of information
um there's there's interpretation and
and the beauty is like they don't have
the reference so they kind of like
extrapolate interpolate that yes yes so
you don't communicate factual
information you communicate how you feel
about something yes uh at least that's
my understanding
so
the um I remember doing
um
improvised musical theater
where the instructors from the
showstoppers uh essentially for leading
UK
um improv committee troupe that has
music or improv
um we are they perform in the West End
um so there were
teaching us how
one if you do not know what you say you
start singing or how to express it you
start singing because you have more
possibilities to express it and at some
point if you no longer know how to sing
it you just start dancing
and so there is this because because it
gets closer and closer to probably the
body I imagine
um and to be literally the visceral
experience
so
where was I heading who's this
um so that means that
when it comes
bring a little bit back to language
models uh
I think that
um what words are or in a way a sort of
a compression of an extremely complex
set of feelings and emotions and
perceptions into symbols and so we share
we communicate with symbols
but as the and compression I really
sound like a computer scientist talking
about biology so
but my city interpretation is that as we
and compressed by the presentation of
symbols in our head
it is something different in everybody's
head which makes for very interesting uh
cases of misunderstandings obviously
but also I guess creates opportunity for
poetry because of
everyone and compressing the the symbols
in their own unique way
and
and so it means that language is a very
imperfect way of communication because
it doesn't convey all those emotions
unless there are lots of shared
references and shared context yes which
I guess
is the reason why art history is so
important
um
and uh
but at the same time it has it fits
inside the book
yes I mean a couple of things there what
really resonated with me is that the
language model is embedded in the kind
of social cognitive ecology so it's not
like that's the end result we're we're
players in the game so we do some
interpretation and but there is a
surprising amount of semantic Capital
embedded into these language models and
presumably that's where most of the
weight space is spent kind of creating
all of these different mappings the
compression thing is quite interesting
because it's not even though I like the
analogy of compression it's not like a
zip algorithm where you have some kind
of mathematical guarantees about the
behavior it's kind of like when you
compress a loaf of red and you get a
turd out yeah
you've got no idea so um so it's a bit
weird isn't it yes and um
what
um what this means uh in terms of I
think research and AI is that we may be
um about focusing only on research on on
language models we are missing quite a
lot of a larger picture yes yes because
we're only capturing the the sequences
of symbols but not uh what generative or
symbols and I think today if there was a
reference during the conference to
embodiment
I think it was during the session on
music
yes it might be Frederick I'm
interviewing him later okay yes I'm a
huge fan of the you know the modern
tradition of cognitive science
so a person who knows much better than
me about this one but
um yes so
the um
that uh the fact that uh language model
is so compressed is
um is of course also the reason why it
was so simple uh in appearance to
develop language models that can predict
something that looks like intelligible
text whereas we are still learning how
to stack cubes or play soccer
football with little robots yes yes
final question
um this was absolutely delicious I was
watching a presentation earlier and
you're talking about dramatron and this
idea about using language models to
create narratives
um in a very creative way but also an
autonomous way and I don't know whether
you're familiar with them
um the very non-automers
yes the I don't I mean we can you could
run the two uh just by itself but what
it would generate would be really very
much something very average very
mediocre yes
um because
um by definition the language models
behind it have been trained on such
large amounts of data given every
context that they need to satisfy all
those data points and so they produce
something average so what really makes
it uh interesting is uh the human
intervention and the human curation to
choose
Pathways in the generation that are more
relevant and more interesting to a human
being and so of course there is an
editorial Choice here
um and uh and also when we're designing
a tool we're really thinking in terms of
not autonomous generation but in terms
of
a writing Aid
that could help a writer
um
throw some words on the page or maybe
get an example of
a banality
or
um so and and move from there or maybe
exploit all the glitches that happen in
text and get inspired from that and
reuse it reuse those in their own
production yes yes exactly because you
know what um humans have this gradient
of interestingness
and so part of creativity is about that
inherent gradient of interestingness but
also it's a random process when you get
lots of individual agents with different
gradients of Interest taking different
trajectories and and so on but but even
in the autonomous domain you know
there's this tree of thoughts thing from
deepmind which is that you actually use
the language model itself to when you're
making these trajectories through
um you know through through generating
words use the language model itself as
as the value function
um I wanted just to quickly go to
something which I thought was really
interesting which is that I'm not sure
if you're aware of the simulators theory
of language models which is that they're
a superposition of agents and there is
an extension of that called the Waluigi
effect yes
and uh so they said that because they're
trained on structured narratology and of
course your winter theater and it's all
about narratology there's something very
deep about narratology and how we
understand the world and everything in
it and do you think that that's a good
way to understand language models
um so that means to understand language
models by
let by letting the generator generation
go further
exactly exactly I mean in this well
Luigi it was like because we do our LH
chef and we have all these agents and
it's supposed to strip the bad agents
out but because of the narrative you
know the narratology and all the stories
it was trained on the waluigi's and the
Luigi's are in the same place in the
embedding space and you get this
regression between them yes but isn't it
a fascinating idea though that you have
this kind of agent-based view of the
behavior of a language model yes so here
if it's uh if you use language agents
you can also play with I mean do
self-play yes and look at what is
generated in the long term so I guess it
could be uh you could get quite uh
faster uh response of what will happen
if
a a human
would be operating those agents yes and
I think that indeed we need to look at
language models not only in terms of
this
question response like interaction but
uh
in terms of what are the second oldest
third older consequences for each choice
made by language model
um
so the that means that um
we can effectively evaluate what happens
during a longer term interaction
and also evaluate other possible risks
and limitations of those language models
amazing and fiata this has been an
absolute honor and a pleasure thank you
thank you so much